oh that's what that looks like um
all right so i have a feeling i'm gonna
do something with this egg at some point
but i feel like that's a lot of egg
for a little kitchen so we'll see how it
goes
hello my name is tai and i'm a
bodybuilder here in los
angeles hey what's up everybody my name
is quan i'm a personal trainer and
bodybuilder and we're gonna be bacon
today
baking is not really my go-to thing i
kind of suck at it but it's one of those
things that i'm good at
in my head i have never baked a cake
before i feel like because it's smaller
it should be easier but i highly doubt
that's gonna be the case
uh first step i'm going to read the box
super moist
we got to preheat our oven all right
let's get it to 350 degrees i'm going to
just eyeball it here so we're gonna
light this um
it says one cup oh that's what that
looks like
let's get some of this batter into i'm
gonna dip this in there
i'm going to just like use the spoon
and dump maybe like four scoops of
that in there
that looks good maybe one more all right
so then crack open this egg
all right what am i gonna whip it with
it says more than one egg but since it's
a smaller portion i'm gonna use
two spoonfuls of egg actually it's kind
of hard to get a spoonful so i'm just
gonna
pour what i think is two spoons okay
it's not stopping there we go
i'm trying to whip this without it
spilling everywhere
that's the thing about this tiny cooking
though a lot of body control
it's probably been probably a few years
i had a cake
last week i probably had like at least
some sort of pastry or cupcake within
the last six months but it's just not
something i eat that often
my favorite type of cake is um
this is the problem i love all types of
cake i'm not that picky
we're getting there
i figured that was gonna happen all
right well we tried to avoid a mess
there
i'm going to add a couple droplets of
water
then put a little butter in there and
now i'm gonna mix it
for the most part it's resembling batter
at least from a texture standpoint
i'm gonna pour the cake batter into
this little muffin container and i think
we're ready to bake
time to put in the oven all right let's
pull it out
i say it looks pretty good it's not as
moist as it
said it would be but maybe i can put
some icing on it and make it
a little better oh this is this is gonna
be fun
oh it's a little dry it's more like a
biscuit but it's okay
i have no idea what i'm doing with this
but i'm gonna just put it on the top
you're gonna glaze that sucker there you
go
got ourselves some writing gel here and
it's blue
oh look at that
that's some sort of cue there there we
go
uh that doesn't look like a smiley face
but definitely
definitely relaxing i feel like i could
have done better but i hope it tastes
okay oh a little crunchy there
not so moist oh that's that's pretty
hard
let's try it out
actually it's not bad
hey it doesn't taste bad i'm not a big
sweets person but to me that
just tastes like it's supposed to it's
pretty good it's just
a little crunchy
[Music]
you